fellow leaders dear prime minister
Sharif this Secretary General Gutierrez
ladies and gentlemen
I would like to thank prime minister
Sharif and Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez for this timely conference
2022 was a difficult year for the world
we just overcame the pandemic and Russia
started its brutal Invasion against
Ukraine but on top of this Pakistan was
hit by one of the biggest natural
disasters anywhere
deadly flooding which affected millions
of people it destroyed livelihoods crops
and infrastructure and put pressure on
the most vulnerable people
the European Union together with its
member states was among the first to
react
our team Europe responds to this tragedy
was immediate and substantial
but the scale of the devastation is
enormous
vast surfaces of cropland and Villages
remained underwater for months nearly 10
million girls and boys remain in need of
immediate support according to UNICEF so
more support is needed
and today we are endorsing an ambitious
reconstruction plan
we are joining forces with our partners
to help put Pakistan on its path to
recovery
our team Europe's support to the
Reconstruction of Pakistan is around 500
million euro including our humanitarian
assistance
and the EU and Pakistan have just agreed
an 87 million euro package
in line with our global gateway strategy
in parallel to keep supporting the
affected communities
the European Union is stepping up its
humanitarian assistance with an
additional 10 million euros
this brings team Europe's humanitarian
support for Pakistan to 172 million
euros
ladies and gentlemen the future of
Pakistan is in the hands of its people
I wish the government of Pakistan every
success with the implementation of is
its ambitious reform plan
we will continue to assist including
through the support group
to be created following this conference
I wish you a very fruitful discussion
thank you very much